principles for success an
extraordinary adventure in a 30
minute, eight episode miniseries first episode the
call to adventure before we begin
let me state that what I know is
a tiny fraction of what I should
know whatever success has had in
my life is  plus a reaction to my not
knowing is the result of my knowing
that I tell others what to do
seems a little presumptuous to me but I will do it
because I believe that the principles that
made me successful can help
others achieve their goals
now I am in  a phase of my life
where it is much more important for me to
pass on what I have learned
about how to be successful rather than
seeking more success for myself it
is up to you to decide what to do with these
principles
you have to think for yourself because
only you can develop the  your
principles based on your personal values
this thought leads me to my first
principle behind everything you have to
think about  re for yourself
to what's true so let's start
at the beginning i found i
need principles principles are
clever ways of handling things that
happen repeatedly in
similar situations there are principles for everything from
skiing to parenting to
cooking and so on i will
share some of my
more encompassing life principles that influence
how we approach everything
we do
i did not start with the principles there or
acquired over a lifetime of
experiences mostly by making mistakes
and reflecting on them.  my
life principles are simple but they are not complete
keep struggling to make the
best decisions i
still make mistakes i always learn new
principles this is the reality in the
beginning i needed to escape
the conventions that surrounded me
this meant i needed to
think for myself  same unless you
want to have a life managed by others
you have to decide for yourself what to do
and where  you have the courage to do it but
I did not know it at the beginning I
learned it only by continuing my
adventure by reviewing my path
now I understand that time is like a
river that pushes us to meet the
reality that forces us to make
decisions  we cannot stop our
movement along this river and we
cannot avoid encounters we can
only deal with them in the best possible way
in your life you will
face millions of decisions the
quality of your decisions will
determine the quality of your life
in the course of my life things  most
precious that I learned were the
results of the mistakes I
reflected on in order to create those
principles that would not make me
commit the same mistakes again these principles
have led me to become from a
very ordinary
middle-class long island boy to a person of great
success by conventional parameters
also gave me important work
and meaningful relationships  cative that I appreciate
even more than these
conventional successes people often wonder
how I did it
I can assure you that it was not because of
my uniqueness as a person it
is the result of a unique approach
to life that in my opinion can be
adopted by almost everyone.
from embracing reality
facing it
in the second episode I will explain
what the path you take
in life means is your most
important decision in my case I wanted
my life to be extraordinary I feared
boredom and mediocrity more than I
feared failure having started
without money and  I just needed a bed to
sleep something to eat
I could guide my decisions to
dedicate myself to my adventures so from an early age he
ran to the things I
wanted
they hit us I got up and chased them again and I
hit them once again every
time I  I bumped against I learned
something good the blow is mitigated
by doing so a thousand voices  lte learned to
love this process until she beat
her nose in this way I encountered
reality and learned to face it
this inspired another of my
most fundamental principles the truth is the
essential foundation for generating good
results
to tell the truth I don't mean anything more
of the way the world works
I believe that we have been given the laws
of reality by nature we have not
created them but we can use them to
promote our own evolution and
reach our goals
the understanding of this has made him
hyper realist meaning that  I have
become someone who has discovered the
paid norms of knowing thoroughly
accepting and working with reality for
what it is and not the way I want it to be
when I say I'm hyper-realistic
sometimes people think I'm
saying dreams can't  becoming
reality is absolutely not true if we do not
pursue dreams life is trivial
I mean that for me them for realism is
the way m  best to choose your
dreams and then make them come true have big
dreams embracing reality as
well as having a lot of determination will
bring you a successful life I think
this formula is valid for everyone but
what a successful life looks like
each of us must decide for himself  what is
success to me it does not matter if you want to
be masters of the universe or live
under a palm tree or whatever
I certainly do not want it each of us
chooses goals based on our
values ​​and decides the best way to
achieve them but  we all
need approaches to make
decisions that work well
especially when it comes to
dealing with problems mistakes and weaknesses
that hinder our path to
be successful we must embrace
all our realities especially the
harsh realities that we wish were not
true
at the beginning look at  these harsh realities
caused me so much suffering but I
learned that this suffering was only
p  and that my different
perspective on things has made a
difference I
have come to see problems
as puzzles that would have
rewarded me if I could have
solved them helped me to address the
problem in question by providing
principles to address similar ones in the
future
I learned to  treating suffering
as a suggestion that a great
learning opportunity is at hand
this led me to realize
that suffering plus reflection equals
progress meditation was extremely
valuable in helping me see
things this way I found that once
calmed down  nor after having embraced
and faced my realities did the rewards give
me pleasure and the pain
vanished each of us has a
unique ability to think logically to
reflect on himself and on his
conditions to guide his
personal evolution doing it right
means simply following a
five-step process in you  third
episode we will analyze how to do it
we have discussed how important it is to
think carefully
after experiencing pain when I
did it I have often been able to
discover principles that would
prevent me from repeating the same mistakes
in the future I could understand that it
happened it simply consisted of
five steps step one is to
know your goals and
pursue them what is best for you
depends on your nature so you
need to really understand yourself and
know what you want to get out of
life step 2 is to address the
problems that hinder
achievement  of your goals
these problems are usually
painful if managed badly some can
lead you to ruin but to evolve
you must identify these problems and
not tolerate them step 3 is to
diagnose these problems to
identify the root causes do not
jump to conclusions too soon take
a step back  And  reflect to
really distinguish the symptoms of the
disease step 4 is to design a
plan to eliminate the problems it is the phase
in which you will decide what to do to
solve them finally step 5 is to
implement these projects by pushing you
to do what is necessary to progress
towards yours  goal
a successful life
essentially consists of these five steps to
follow and repeatedly
this is your personal evolution
and this process you see it everywhere it is
just a law of nature
think of a product to an
organization or a person you
know and you will see how this is  true
to
them evolution is simply a process
of adaptation or death
on a conceptual level it just resembles
the five-step process that I have
described as pushing you through this
often painful process you will
naturally rise and higher and higher levels of
success I have found that by putting in more effort.
my fight has never become more
easy because the more capable I became the
bigger the challenges were
because different subjects are strong and
weak in different things
most people
fail to follow all
five steps properly not facing this
reality means you may try
harder than you should  and if the heights
increase also the falls could
be worse they can happen to all
of us terrible things in life they
can ruin us or they can improve us
profoundly depending on how
we manage them something like this
happened to me in 1982 in the fourth episode I
will show you what it is  success and what
I have done
we progress until we
meet obstacles if we get rid of them we
keep moving forward or spiral
down depends on how
willing we are to face
failure objectively and make the
right decisions to turn the
situation around again  upwards in 1982
something terrible happened to me  when i
bet everything i had on a
depression that never comes
between 1979 and 1982 there was a period
of extreme turbulence in the
global economy of the markets and for me and believers
that the united states economy with its
world economy was
heading towards a catastrophe
this view was
extremely controversial i wanted the big upside
kit very openly a big
risk and i was absolutely wrong absolutely
wrong after a delay
the stock market went into the big
18 year rise and the us
economy good at the period  of
greatest growth in his history
this experience was like a blow
to the head
I had to reduce my losses so
that my bridgewater company was left with an
employee
I was so broke I had to
borrow $ 4,000 from my father to
pay my bills even worse  it was having to
let go of the people I cared about
so much I wondered if I had to
give up my dream  to work for
myself and play at home working
for someone else with a job that
would have forced me to commute every day in jackets and ties
even though
I knew and for me taking less risks
would have meant having a less
extraordinary life feeling so wrong and
especially so openly wrong it was
painfully humiliating i am still shaken
embarrassed by my presumption
in my being totally confident in
an absolutely wrong view
even though i was right is much
more than
i was wrong i let a bad bet
erase all my good  bet
I have thought a lot about the relationship between
risk and reward and how to manage them
but I did not see a way that would have
rewarded me as I wanted without
incurring unacceptable risks
this type of experience happens all it
will happen to you you
will lose something or someone without
whom you do not believe you can  live or
suffer from a terrible one  illness or
offense or your career will break
before your eyes
you may think that your life is
ruined and that there is no way to go
on but it will pass
I assure you that there is always a
better way to go probably you do
not see it yet just reflect  well
to find it you have to embrace
your reality in the fifth episode I
will illustrate how this awareness
prompted me to ask myself how
reality works and how to best deal with it
sometimes difficult things happen to
understand life often becomes
difficult and complicated it goes beyond what
we can tolerate in  once
my inner torment led me to
reflect deeply on my circumstances
it also led me to reflect on
nature because it guides us to the truth
then I thought a lot knows how
things work which
helped me to put myself and  my circumstances
in perspective
I saw that at the big bang all the laws
and forces of the universe were c  realities
and projected forward in a mutual
exchange like the
perpetual motion machine in which all the fragments to the
pieces merge forming machines that
for a while do their job
disintegrate and rejoin forming
new machines this continues
for eternity
I have seen  that everything is a machine
the structure is the evolution of
galaxies the formation of our
solar system
the constitution of the
terrestrial geography of ecosystems our
economies and markets and each of us
individually are machines
made up of different machines our
circulatory system our system
our thoughts our
dreams our emotions and all the other
aspects of our distinct characters
all these different machines
evolve together over time to produce
the realities we encounter every day and
I realized that I was just a tiny
fragment that in a  nanosecond had to
decide what to do with
this attitude  nto may seem very
philosophical
on the other hand I found it very practical
because it showed me how I could
treat my realities in a
better way for example I observed that
almost everything happens repeats itself over and over again
the slightly different ways some in
children obvious ways  easy to recognize by
enabling us to know how to
proceed like the 24-hour day
others so rarely that they have never
happened in our lives and when they do
we are amazed with a
storm that happens once every
hundred years and of some phenomena we know
the  existence but we meet them for the
first time as the birth of our
first child almost all of them mistakenly
treat these situations as unique
and treat them without due perspective
or without principles to guide them
to extricate themselves
I have found that instead of treating
these events as events a  tantum
I could consider them as yet another
of the many and relate to them in the
same way in  which a biologist
relates to an animal by
first identifying the species and
then relying on some principle
to treat it adequately since I was
able to see that these events
occurred in a very similar way
as they repeated I could see more
clearly the cause and
effect relationships  that governed its
behavior and this allowed me to
develop better principles
and could express both in words and
algorithms I learned that while almost
everyone expects the future to be a
slightly modified version of the
present it is normally very different
this happens because people are
influenced by recent history and
neglect events that have not happened for a
long time perhaps even in
the span of their lives but are repeated without
that perspective I realized that what
escaped me when he mistakenly
invoked a great depression was
hidden in the patterns of history and
I could use the  recent acquaintance with
qu  These patterns for making
better decisions in the future and when I
paused to think about my challenge of
balancing risks and rewards I
realized that risk and reward
naturally go hand in hand I
could see to extract more from life you
need to take more risk is that
knowing how to balance  adequately
risk and reward essential to
enjoy the maximum possible life
imagine you are faced with the
choice of having a safe but
boring life if you stay where you are or of
having a fairytale one if you take the risk
of crossing a dangerous jungle
on healthy outings this is essentially
the choice we all face for me
the choice was clear but it does not mean
that the path to take was free
of hindrances
I still have to face two big
barriers as we all must in the
sixth episode I will let you
know precious techniques that I have learned on the
best way to do it
I am not able to tell you which is the
mig  lior path of life for you not
knowing how important it is for you to
achieve great goals compared to the
importance it attaches to avoiding the
travails that reach them
this is the courage I was talking about and
we all have to stick to our
personal feeling after my big
mistake  committed in predicting
depression had come to one of the living
we all get to in life if i had
made the choice of a
normal restful job i would have ended up leading a
completely different life from the one
i led but once had to
pay  the rent to feed the family
and educate the offspring the only
plausible choice was to take risks and
cross the jungle in search
of the best possible life
my big mistake in betting
on depression gave me a healthy
fear of being wrong.
other words gave me a deep
unity which was exactly what
I needed
at the same time not  it prevented me from
eagerly pursuing the things I
wanted to succeed I had to
see more than an
individual is allowed to see but two colossal barriers stood in my way
that we all
encounter our ego
and blind spot barriers these barriers
exist by virtue of functioning  of
our brain
we first explore the
ego barrier when I talk about your
ego barrier I talk about the parts of
your brain that prevent you from
objectively acknowledging
your weakness so that you can
figure out how to deal with your
innermost needs and fears  reside
in areas of the brain that control
emotions and are not accessible to
your high level conscious self and
as our need to be
right may be more important than
our need to find out what is
true
we love to believe in our opinions
without subjecting them to  an adequate
stress test is particularly unwelcome to
us  in the face of our mistakes and
weaknesses we are instinctively led to
react to achille probes as if they were an
aggressor and we get irritated even if it would be
more logical to be open to the opinion of
others
this leads us to make
unhappy decisions to learn and less and
to stay below our
potential
the second is the barrier of the blind spot
we all have blind spots the
barrier of the blind spot and when a
person is convinced that he can see
everything but it is a foregone conclusion that no one
can have a complete picture of
reality, of
course it is not possible to evaluate
what you cannot
see because we all have different
vocal excursion abilities acuity
of hearing and ability to perceive
colors
we have different parameters according to
which to see and understand things
for example some people are good at
seeing the big picture while others
they are very good at welcoming details
some think linearly and others
are  more lateral
some are creative but unreliable
others are reliable but not creative and
so on
by virtue of the way our
brains differ in making
connections everyone perceives the
world around them differently in doing
what comes naturally to us
.  our weaknesses and we
crash or we continue to do so or
we change Aristotle defined tragedy
as a terrible result
of a person's fatal flaw a flaw that if it
had been healed would have led to a
happy result
in my opinion these two barriers are
the main impediments to  getting
to make good
decisions my fear of being wrong
gave me the inherent open-mindedness
I needed and that changed everything
taking risks and being
occasionally ruined was not
acceptable nor was it to shy away from
risks without achieving exceptional results
I needed an approach that would give me
the exceptional result if  not too much
tierney the catastrophic implication when
he discovered it turned out to be my holy
grail to conquer it I had to replace
the joy of proving to be
right with the joy of learning the
truth this need prompted me to
seek the greatest number
of discerning people  that they
disagree with me
I didn't care about their conclusions
I just wanted to see things through
their eyes and let them see things
through mine so that
jointly we could sort out the
truth in other words what I
wanted most from them was a
reasoned disagreement proceed
from observing things only with my
eyes
to seeing them through the eyes of these
people discerning it was like going from
seeing things in black and white to
seeing them to color the world was flooded
with walnut it was then that I
realized that  the best way to get
through the jungle of life was
with people capable of reasoning who
saw things  and differently from me
you think about the five step process
I described earlier as I was saying because
we have such different brain connections
not everyone can walk
five steps well but you don't have to
go through them all alone you can
enlist the help of others who are
good at  the one in which you are not
that they are equipped with receivers of the things
that escape you
all you have to do get rid
of the mania of having the right answers
within you and use your fear of
being wrong but for the earth your
mind
other views
in this way you can turn
your attention to the risks and opportunities that
alone would escape you I found that
taking this approach of great
openness and credibility in weighing the
thoughts of others greatly increased
my chances of making the best
possible decisions this allowed me
to raise them to  higher peaks and towards
greater challenges in the past I always
wanted to do what den  I thought better of myself
but at that point
I was looking for the most knowledgeable
independent thinkers I could find
I still do it there is nothing better
than being on a common mission with
extraordinary people who can be
radically truthful and radically
transparent to each other this approach I
led to create a company with a
unique meritocracy of ideas operating
in a unique way that achieved
unique successes in a meritocracy of ideas you
extract the best from anyone
everyone thinks independently then
divergences are analyzed to get
the best
however not all  opinions are
equally valuable and we had to
learn to distinguish three good and
bad ideas to reach the best decisions
in other words we had to weigh the
credibility of people's reasoning
but here we are in another area which I
will illustrate in my award
principles work now there are many opportunities
fantastic and huge risks that surround you
anus and you do not see if you saw them
free from the distortions produced by
go and from your blind spots you could
face them with greater incisiveness if you
manage to acquire this faculty
and with practice you will be able to
totally improve your life
in the eighth episode I will conclude
our journey together in  so that
you can start yours
so far I have described how I learned to
deal with my realities my
problems my mistakes and weaknesses and how I
surrounded myself with others who did
things better than me this was
the most effective way I had discovered
to  making decisions guess
this is not the normal way of being
but through this approach
i have achieved success and being
successful has allowed me to meet
extraordinarily successful people and
see how they think i found that
their travels were similar to mine is not
apparent  but everyone struggles and everyone has
weaknesses that they win by working with
others who  they see risks and opportunities
that would have escaped
them over time I have learned that by
nature people's greatest
strengths are also related to their
most significantly weak points
fighting hard for great things will
bring you ruinous falls is only part
of the  process
these setbacks will
test you categorize people
some ponder
what caused the setbacks learn their lesson
and keep progressing towards their
goals while others decide this
game is not for them and clear the
field I have come to the conclusion
that success is not a matter of
reaching one's goal
I have found that when it reaches each
new greater level of success it is
seldom satisfied that the
things we strive for are but the lure
striving for them obliges us to
evolve and this struggle
towards  personal evolution with others is
the reward
I no longer wanted through  I would be the jungle
but find ever greater challenges to
pursue
surrounded by great people who
work together on a
common path over time the success of the
mission and the well-being of the people
next to me have become more
important than my own success
I also wanted to see  beyond myself and
I wanted others to succeed
when I was
gone I understand that if I can't it will have been
a failure
now this is my struggle
we all struggle with different things at different times
until we decide to give up or
succumb by entering to do  part of the
evolutionary history in a broad sense and this
way of functioning and recycling of all
the machines over time when a
machine breaks
down its parts return to the system to
become parts of the new machines that
also evolve over time
sometimes this makes us sad because
we are  become very attached to
our machines but if you look in
perspective it really is but  I can see
how the evolution machine works
now you have to decide for yourself how to
volver and you forget where
these principles come from,
only evaluate if they are useful to you and let them
evolve to adapt them to your
needs
as with all the decisions of life
what you will do with them
it is up to you in the last resort my only
hope is that you have the courage to
fight with valentia
thanks
and goodbye
[Music]